you guys may remember barack obama he
was the president
uh for eight years before donald trump i
actually voted for obama twice i
completely regret it
and you should judge me accordingly but
i was a democrat i was a progressive i
was a lefty i suppose i was brainwashed
at some level that's actually what my
whole political
story is about the whole reason that so
many of you guys dig what i do because i
was honest about my political evolution
and i truly regret
voting for obama i think the country
would be in very different shape if
mccain had won
the first time around or even if romney
had won the second time around i have no
love for romney by the way
i think he's basically just a pet
republican but it probably would have
been better
than obama uh because obama loves this
sort of double speak
stuff too but right now
uh obama's been talking about
misinformation
and uh he doesn't like misinformation
although what he means by misinformation
is stuff that goes against the narrative
that he likes we've got some quotes here
from cnn
former president barack obama said
tuesday that the rise in misinformation
that led to the january
6th insurrection was apparent during his
administration
but the speed and prevalence with which
misinformation has increased in recent
years worries him
and should worry everyone the guardrails
i thought were in place around many of
our democratic institutions really
depend
on the two parties agreeing to those
ground rules
and that one of them right now doesn't
seem as committed to them
as in previous generations that worries
me obama said and i think
we should all be worried one of the
perpetrators of that not the originator
of it but somebody who surfed
that for their own advantage was my
successor donald trump he said
and we saw how powerful the
constellation of conservative media
outlets talk radio and then ultimately
all of this gets turbocharged with
social media how powerful that is now
first off
there's so much here because if you
remember when obama remember hope and
change and everybody was like
drinking ecstasy all day long when obama
was running the first time around and
everything was amazing and wonderful and
spectacular there were a
gajillion i think that's a scientific
term
i think i'm getting it right in the
amount there were a gajillion articles
written
how obama and the obama machine had
leveraged
social media to get his message out
there and kids were on instagram
and facebook campaigns and it was
exciting and new ways of sharing
information it was all wonderful
so it's wonderful when they do it then
when trump supporters couple years later
start sharing memes online and doing
funny videos of trump and putting his
head
on a dancing man and all of the other
stuff that happened then they're
sharing misinformation they're super
charging
scary stuff okay so first off that's
just like a general part of it when they
do it
right it's good it's fun it's great we
write articles about how wonderful it is
a new generation figuring out how to
spread information
when the bad guys do it it's evil and we
must figure out a way to stop it okay
fine um now of course what obama really
is saying there
is that people are talking and they're
talking about things that he doesn't
like right they're talking about how
wokeness is bad
they're talking about how critical race
theory is bad he doesn't want
people to be able to push back when the
media pushes a hoax
the very fine people on both sides think
that was a complete hoax when they said
trump
said that because the sentence before
was i completely condemned the neo-nazis
but you never see that right
the the covington kids hoax as you know
brett kavanaugh is a racist
jessie smallett was was uh attacked by
white maga supporters while eating a
subway sandwich
the endless amount of stuff that we know
that they lie about if it wasn't
for conservative youtubers or
radio or whatever ability people still
have to be online to push back against
this
then all of their lies would in in
in sort of actuality they would be the
truth because there would be no way to
prove that they weren't true so it would
be the totality of everything
so thank god there is some counter thing
this is also the constant obsession
that these people have with getting fox
news off the air they
constantly are angry that people are
watching fox news and it's like
well why are people watching fox news
maybe some people agree with that maybe
some people would like a counter opinion
rather than just the blue and on stuff
that cnn and msnbc
are sharing with people so then what do
they do they start campaigns to get rid
of tucker's
advertisers to make sure that no
respectable person will go on fox news
or anything else and ironically they
then drive more traffic to it because
then fox news
is the outlier and i think one thing
that's that's good that's happening
right now
is conservative leaning people are
actually realizing that we got to build
our own stuff we gotta fight back we
gotta stop listening to these hysterical
children
and you know i was on a uh i was on a
youtube show in spain today uh don't
burn this book came out in spain a
couple weeks ago it's been number one
it's actually been the number one
um non-fiction book uh for quite some
time now since it came out
which is absolutely great and uh the
host was telling me how spain
is going through so many of the things
that we're going through that it just
sort of what america what happens in
america basically trickles everywhere
else two to three years later
and that actually is getting
supercharged by algorithms now so the
two to three year window that they used
to have as the buffer
is now getting smaller and smaller um
but we were talking about
sort of my political evolution and that
really i just started talking about all
of this stuff and that's what woke
people up and
that in many ways is what obama fears
that's what the machine
fears right like what do i tell you guys
all the time you don't have to agree
with everything i say here i actually
welcome you know in the reuben 4
community sometimes after the show
people post you know dave i didn't
really agree with that
or i think you missed this point on this
or that or the other thing and it's like
i love that i love that exchange that
that's what it's all about
and by the way you know i like
correcting myself if we get something
wrong factually here i do it in the
middle of the show sometimes
i'm not perfect i'm one guy i got two
guys in here we're putting on something
that i think is
is slim and trim and worthy and that's
why you're watching
but that's what the machine doesn't want
right so when obama's talking about
misinformation
he doesn't really mean misinformation he
means the stuff
that he disagrees with